Well you know. OK but for which she's. Not not a chance. Or not ever ever and ever actually.
Was well because we're not machines and we're not governed by our brains do not work through algorithms
and we don't work in binary logic.
So we have components of our minds there are analog very important components
and we all know that digital processes can live. They can approximate but they cannot emulate.
Another log process particularly processes like the ones that take place in our minds.
You know the brain is a very complex system
and it is formed by one hundred one hundred billion elements connected to each other which are continuously adapting to
the statistics of their outside world
and it is at that tension that we call plasticity makes it impossible for a dish to machine then its code to run.
So there is no software
and hardware in the brain as the other thing very very Yet as an organic computer the brain computes with the organic
tissue. There is no he has and then death kind of computation is not reducible to an algorithm.
So there is no singularity coming for the human race.
There are other problems that computers can bring to the human race
but not replacing our minds because it Dinara Safina brain. Absolutely.
A brain is a system dead it is a product of a evolutionary process that involved millions of random steps that cannot
be simulated in a laboratory or in a machine. And my concern is not there.
Computers digital computers will reproduce the brain. My main concern is there. The brain is so adaptable.
So plastic any any absorbs everything that is relevant gives the brain.
Larry advantage
and a survival advantage that we've made because we are continuously exposed to computers digital machines I mean our
this is exposure is becoming almost overwhelming. There we may start reducing our human condition.
To mimic machines and what is going to be rewarded out there is behavior is there are similar to machines
and so the brain would assimilate machines
and behave like machines produce behaviors like machines eliminating the most important things that define our human
condition. And you know you're afraid because where might be frustration from Star.
Actually my fascination started when I read a science fiction book based ACAS more of
when I was in high school here in Brazil and.
It was a kind of boring book because I liked his occurs more for this science fiction books
but then I found this book the brain.
In one of the few books that he wrote that is not really science fiction and it was a description and in the book.
There was no dynamics there was no physiology there was mainly anatomy.
But I realized that I was for the first time introduced to do things the really creative everything. And.
And then
when I went to medical school which there were computers my computers are just coming out in the eighty's here in
Brazil and I and I thought for a moment. OK I'm going to work.
I'm going applications or computers in medicine because I'd like very much to have.
And then I thought well but the ultimate computing device is the brain
and at that time I didn't really need to know much about either computers or the brain
but I decided that I wanted to understand the brain first and there was thirty five years ago.
I'm still trying to understand the brain first. Because really first to New York first something first again.
Then the next circles as you start to stand for it. Yeah when I came to neuro science in eighty two eighty three.
Again there was no dynamics there was no time in the brain.
Most of the descriptions were very static we talk of MAMP Skala means.
Areas so the areas soup quits but there was no flow.
There was the whole changing plasticity was reported in eighty three by by now one of my heroes of my good friend John
Karr's and his colleague Mike Merzenich two papers they were rejected everywhere
and they only got published in a new journal because people didn't want to see it.
Their brain a proof that the adult brain was changing it was a bad adapting to lesions in the periphery that's how they
showed it and I wasn't aware of this paper and chew eighty five.
AM But
when I saw the paper in our two papers actually I I started wondering if this is this is totally different than what I
have been you know reading. And that's when I went for my Ph D.
Here in Brazil after medical school
and I realized that I what I want to look into the brain was the dynamics of the brain because I had a hand.
It was very fate there was not a very concrete thing there.
There was much more to plus this didn't just what the John
and Mike had reported in turn out the plasticity is pretty much what matters in the brain is the central concept of the
brain. So I'm I'm absolutely shocked that these guys have not want to love a prize yet.
You know people have one other prices lately for a minute tiny things.
These guys discover the essence of what the brain is about you know
and really because they're pretty certain stand the brain as far as you.
So I understand the immense possibility when you combine great things for future reference.
Well we're in a way when I went to the US A man just another phenomenal guy John chip in and we had the same idea.
We are one of the few people in the world at that time. Today's common ground. But at that time.
If in fact people
when they heard what we wanted to do require for multiple neurons multiple brain cells simultaneously in behaving
animals so we could look at the dynamics of this circuit.
Some of our colleagues more senior colleagues started we're nuts that we're crazy that there was no point in moving
from recording the electrical signals of one there are too many near us.
So John and I had a lot of opposition
and our careers where you know on the fringe at that time he was already established guy but even so he was young
and I was just nobody coming from Brazil and I opposed doc
but it turned out that what we discussed in the early ninety's
and the studies that we published them then I think are now pretty much at the center of neuroscience and the edge
and in almost disparate in eighty ninety seven we had many papers published
but people are not really pay attention to them. We discussed.
One day that we needed a preparation you preparation to convinced our colleagues. There.
This thing that we're talking about population coding was much more relevant than anything to have been done before in
terms of single neurons and that's
when we came up with the idea of brain machine interfaces of linking brains to devices.
It was a preparation experimental part of the time that we created to test the notion that to control a device either a
limb a real limb a leg or arm or an eye Fisher device the brain requires lots of mirrors not a single cell
and we prove that quantitatively when you let the animals you.
Only one neuron to control a complex device where nothing happened. But when you get a population of cells.
They're working together they were able to use just the brain activity to control devices.
With rats
and we did with rats first the new A year later we did that was the first paper very much interface for the modern age
with the concept we defined a term I published a paper in Nature in two thousand that actually started with a
description of these goals that you see here to explain what a population called means because this is the go to score
in which a Brazilian players starts the ball without any Talim being able to touch it
and many of the individual players knew the outcome of the play until kind of a bear to kick the ball in the goal was
scored so that's what I was trying the message the metaphor was to explain the man of the individual neurons know what
is going on is the population is the team there knows the outcome.
And so I started a paper and in the middle the paper said what John
and I have proposed a year ago we call it brain machine interface and the term was created
and they're a year later we did in monkeys.
And in our monkeys in one reasons one case and in two thousand
and four we did the first human demonstration of this concept into operative procedure in Parkinsonian patients just
for a few minutes
but it was the first human demonstration that everything we had seen in monkeys was a political Whoa whoa whoa whoa we
saw it was does this seem funny does neuronal seem from the properties the dynamic properties that we signed Reds
and monkeys were there in humans. It was the same thing.
And if same lead to magical competition or approach that we used to link and the brain.
We were devise would work in humans and so badly is when we realized that we had something gigantic
and there was not just a basic science apparatus
or part of that time we had to touch something that could have clinical relevance.
And you could advance narrow sysctl realities that we never thought about before but
when you look at our trees our princes from certainty Yeah.
Where are you going for I don't think anybody can answer that nobody can answer that question honestly because every
day things are changing but is a completely different neuroscience is a completely different brain research.
You know or if you look at the BRAIN Initiative
and I states that I'm not part of never got invited to be everything that initiatives about is what John and I did
and is about recording more and more near us studying only circuits paying attention
but they never have plasticity creating technology to visualize thousands millions of neurons.
However the emphasis is mainly on technology and I think the emphasis should be in the questions.
It should be in the real science. You know curiosity should be the emphasis I think.
But as you know technology in the U.S.
Has become a month almost a religion taught to the point where some people predicted we would be replaced by technology.
Which is against the idea that there are no derivative of a biological system
or of can be more complex than the biological system they created that the riveted.
Technology is just a projection of our mind
and we can never be more complex than the mind who created the technology harem scarem is wrong nor Parker yet
but you yourself are developing in your science big steps. Well to display true.
Well we first started with the brain machine interface concept right.
When we discovered that we could link brains of rats monkeys
and humans to a upper limb robotic device there was a physical robot a seven degree of freedom industrial robot
and he worked. That was the first thing but then we said why why need to be a problem. Why could it be lower limb.
Nobody went for we're the only lab one of the few labs in the world perhaps two or three labs in the world.
They said OK let's try for Lex and he works. And so and then we said well why he has to be a robot.
Why can't I be a virtual device can a brain.
Incorporate a victory device as if it were a part of the subjects body a real you know flesh and bone. And you Art.
We put our avatar of limbs and legs or arms and the monkey is treated that after a while as if they were a third
or fourth.
So we had my kids we're four limbs two biological
and two literal same thing with legs then we said wow the actuator doesn't need to be next to the monkey.
So we put her back to we're in Japan a robot in Japan
and we had a monkey in the United States controlling the across the globe and longer be hoed.
The monkey assimilated the legs of the robots as if you know it were there are his own legs
and you could stop the treadmill when the mike was walking and Duke. And he would still keep imagining.
Movements for the robot to walk in Japan.
And as long as you give a reward you know monkeys are like us you know they need a bribe or two to work.
And so as long as you keep giving them juice or grapes they would do that.
So then we went further and said Why does need to be just one brain
and could we have multiple brains collaborating mentally to act she of this movement.
So that's what we call a brain that in we just published a year ago showing the three monkeys that though even know
they're there next to each other because in different rooms they don't know of the existence of the other guys they can
mentally collaborate to make a virtual army make certain movements there are enough in form to the to the monkey is how
they should do it. And so if you give monkey one the job of controlling the axe. And Y..
Dimensions of the movement this is a three D. Movements X. Y. and Z. Monkey wonders X. and Y. Monkey to the Y. and Z.
In my Q three does X. and Z. You need at least two monkeys to get a three D. Out of this but if you get a third guy.
It looks much better to the results much credit can get all rewarded very quickly and at the same time.
Well the monkeys get together synchronize their brains and they work as if. They were part of a single brain.
In this experiment and I think our colleagues have not seen it
and they thought it was just a some of them thought it was just a trick just a you know some kind of Hollywood kind of
thing is not we actually use that to show how a single brain may synchronize to operate.
Because there's a big mystery how multiple areas of your brain actually come together at the precise moment in time to
do a job to make my arms move to make me speak to make me reason nobody knows nobody knows what the synchronization
happens well it turns out that if you put motor brains separately.
And you give a common feedback to them they synchronize so I think we found a very profound rule of
when highlight Cayle when millions of people watching T.V. The same T.V. Show around the country around the globe.
In the horse encounters and when you're in the stadium seeing the same match the fans there.
They all synchronize so I think we found what is going on what happens
when multiple individuals are recruited to be part of a structure
and that's reason I'm calling this is structure being there are multiple Lance working together beasts of birds flying
together in a flock fish swimming together too many humans in a movie theater
or in a stadium I'm calling these are again a computer because it is a super nice device that is computing.
In a domain analog digital computers cannot get there. Enough.
So there is how we have evolved of these
and of course five years ago we decided OK this clinical relevance of this thing
and we may make people benefit from brain machine interfaces by restoring mobility to them as reason you've seen this
lab year as what we came to Brazil and decided to do this for the World Cup first but the project has continued
and our big biggest discovery. We're British interface I think in a decade. Is there.
If apparently if you're exposed chronically to a use of a brain machine interface
or a paradigm in which your control of your mind something in your getting rich visual tactile feedback you start
getting for a paralyzed person with a lesion in the spinal cord.
You may start getting recovery of motor in tactile behaviors Beadle old the level of the lesion which it has never been
demonstrated with other techniques.
So these are chronic patients many years after the accident and yet in almost eighty percent of them after two years.
We are seeing that they are recovering control of muscles in the legs.
They now can Few their bodies below the level the lesion
and I think is related to the training that they were exposed to.
There was I'm saying is we did the Create a actually a skeleton of a robotic vest controlled by brain activity
and we asked for man to the effects of skeleton to deliver feedback back to the subject.
So the subject every time he steps on the ground.
There are sensors in this surface of the foot of the eggs are there detect the pressure of the contact that pressure
signal is then deliver to the skin of the arm of the patients because it's one of the few parts of the body where the
original We have tactile sensation and by adapting the parameters of the speed in the magnet to that is pressure away.
On the screen. We induced the phenomena phantom limb sensation.
So we fooled the brain of these guys to feel through their arms their legs so they report to us that they have a walk
with their own legs
and they are touching the ground they begin even tell you what the ground is in are they can tell where the ground is
grass where the ground is sand or if it is hot asphalt. So these three floors they can distinguish with this system.
But then we only want to originally to restore mobility put them in a device link the device to their brains
and get them to walk again there was original game but one and
but we always did the neurological examination as a routine for us. You know and we didn't expect to see any change.
Well six months a month after the World Cup Six months after the training started we started saying that is guys were
having motor contractions or muscles below the level of the lesion.
And seven of these guys had a complete clinical lesion. Which means after ten years.
Had you shouldn't see anything you should have seen motor contractions voluntary motor contractions
or muscles they should not have doctor you're feeling.
And they should not have visual feeling so they don't lead they couldn't feel for instance the women could not feel
when the period days of the month are well we start getting reports from the two women who live in the projects.
Look like I can feel when my peers coming.
I actually can feel that I need to go to the bathroom now I can I can control my brother now several of them start
telling us and then when we did the motor test.
We measure quantitatively the contraction force other sudden we had a woman with twenty new terms of force which is the
little kind of force to do you need to make to start moving and we started looking if you do muscles
and we could attack the contractions. So we really did the classification is called Asia.
And it is the American spinal cord injury questions a standard code. Gone step.
There of classify patients over the world.
These guys were seven of them were Asia eight which means complete paralysis in one was a should be which is sort of
intermediate. Well in six months fifty percent of them were promoted to Asia see which is partial spinal cord injury.
Two years later remarkable and we're not talking about guys that came to sixty feet for air.
We started training them in November two thousand and thirteen.
So six months after their training started at a one month after the World Cup after we lost to the Dutch.
And I shouldn't say that on camera in which my passport but it was something in the food.
I have to say but in any event sick one month after the World Cup ended
and we had done our demo which was seen by a one point two billion people.
We didn't or a large protest and long
and behold half of the patients had muscle contractions that they could control they could actually generate movements
the visual you can see the movements. When you put them up right. They could simulate walking.
You know and we keep doing it. We keep doing the training.
Now this December we completed two years of training we really did the neurological exam
and now seventy eight percent of the patients have recovered movement saw six out of eight have muscle control below
the level is not complete. But it is something that has never been seen.
So the hypothesis that we have based on the studies they were forgotten in the sixties and seventies.
And Australian pathologist had done a lot of the top says in Australian spinal cord injury patients that died of
natural causes.
And he he realised that in the last sixty percent of the patients are classified clinically as being completely
paralyzed. There is at least. Two to twenty percent of fibers of nerves in the spinal cord it is to connect it.
They're not totally destroyed but they're quite very likely they went blank. I think our training.
Now when I read this paper.
I want my hypothesis is that the training the intensive training that we do the brain machine interface of the patients
turn on their arms again in the brain in these neurons sister say messages down to the spinal cord through this X.
As they were quiet but it's still there.
So it's plasticity is what job has it might resonate predicted from over me when you were using through your future.
Now there's a horrible feeling the possibilities are tremendous.
You know because you have twenty five million people in this condition spinal cord injury paralysis in the world.
Imagine now if I large percentage of them can recover some movement some control because for instance one of our
patients while our the women in the group says now she had perineal sensation.
She decided to become pregnant and she actually could feel the delivery.
You know she had bladder control so she went to work two of our patients got jobs because they now could get out of
house. They didn't need to wear diapers anymore to you know we don't think about it.
We had one patient who was hyper tense his normal tense now because the kind of vascular system performs better
when we're upright
and she says one hour a day two days a week is enough for the kind of master system to recover the blood vessels to
open up. So his blood pressure went down.
So being up and walking is a major behavior for we humans and you know this guy's lost weight
and some of them were overweight because of being a world wheelchair too long a decade or so off
and for of this very important understand it's major major breakthrough for you are to understand brain connect brains.
Off drugs or what holds a future for us.
Oh there are many things I mean you saw the prototype of our brain that for humans.
So we're about to get a patient naïve Patient A hasn't been trained yet in our part of that which takes some weeks
but we want to reduce this training time because the beginner train is very difficult patient has to really concentrate
them in the beginning is a little frustrating because the brain has forgotten what is to walk.
Actually the brain has forgotten what is the concept of having lower limbs so to virtual reality training we need to
reintroduce to the brain the concept or you have legs this body has legs and they move.
And we do that by having the patient try to control avatar or himself or herself walking along virtual space
and it takes many weeks for the patients to get this done.
Well we're going to start linking the brain of this patient a long invasive way we've E.G.
As you saw we have a physical therapist there is really well trained in that task a normal person would now I wouldn't
say normal but a person that can walk by herself.
And we're going to link the brains in to begin to train ninety percent to ninety five percent of the signal comes from
the healthy physical therapist and five
or ten percent comes from the patient who has a spinal cord injury so he's going to get his brings about to get
rewarded faster and he's going to have the impression there.
He's controlling the device and I think then what your vision the context is the driving force for plus distance.
My prediction is that we are going to celebrate the learning curve because we are going to celebrate persisting.
So the brain.
NET is going to have a very practical clinic up occasion almost instantaneous to burn off
and you've written very very stars. There are very few world history is yes.
The problem is that the noninvasive technology that we use E.G. The one that you know you just put in this.
It doesn't have the same resolution and the same.
Information content is not as rich in information we need to the place of mathematical tricks to get information out of
the signal. So it's not as rich as implanting things in the hat.
So I'm not suggesting they're implant people in the head just so they play video games
but yes is a is a proof of concept the mental collaboration.
If we get better not invasive techniques in the future become part of all I mean E.G.
Now is wireless here as you saw you know you can have wireless broadcasting we have a paper coming this week I'll do
all that uses invasive technology in the monkeys showing that monkeys can learn to drive wheelchairs in open space in
our lab mentally.
So you see a Mikey sitting on the wheelchair and she's driving
or he's driving there which are to the part of where we're delivering grapes.
But every movement of their wheelchairs coming from the mind of the monkey via a wireless link.
So is five hundred euros fine wirelessly broadcasting the signal wirelessly so the motors are there would share a turn
around and go up to the part of very professional corner.
Sir we already have an experiment in the lab where to work is a collaboration there are two each monkey has its own
wheelchair. And they only get rewarded if both of them get to the part.
So the faster monkey helps those lower Bucky to get in on the them selves together at the party at the same time so we
are ready for any brain networking. Between two monkeys.
You're not really you know knowing humans we're using for clinical rehab at this point
but if yes it's conceivable that if we prove the bend with any feeling proved the Howard methods to extract information
from this from the brain in a noninvasive way you could have over the Internet
and millions of people collaborating on a common task so. Wow there's a future of your powers the world. In fact.
Our there's a very good question.
I think the in one direction we're going to increase the clinic
or pick ations because what we saw for spinal cord injury. I think may be a political two stroke victims.
It may be a political to other neurological disorders.
They require plasticity in effect to have a cheery that I'm about publish
and I'm going to put in my new book of the most neurological psychiatric disorders independently of their it's your
logic but the cause of this disease.
Let's say Parkinson's disease is we know that you in developed markets
or if you're of the cells that contain a particular chemical dopamine is start dying.
OK but once they start dying what we discover him in animals
and then in humans is that the lack of dopamine produces like a pleasure to see here a low level Corona exit
and that explains the tram are in a difficulty to move.
Well we discover that if we put a microchip in the spinal cord in send electrical pulses of the right frequency a tiny
left proposes but a very high frequency we disrupt a seizure and the animals in the patients seem to get better.
So I think this kind of concept that neurological disorders are designers of neuronal timing how they fire together.
If they fire too much is not good together.
So I think I'm going to in one part of my work increase the scope of the use of brain machine interfaces to treat their
logical disorders as one. From a basic science point of view. I have two other branches.
One is to push very hard to understand the kind of computation that the brain does that is different from digital
machines.
So I'm building models
and a lot of models of the brain to it particularly study more detailed interaction of the brain magnetic fields with
the neurons and see if this analog digital interaction does what I like.
To say a recursive analog digital interaction explains why the brain is different from a digital machine as one line of
work and the other is to continue to push the envelope on trying to see how large SUV quits
and behaving animals operate so at our lab is like has now the world record the number of layers a record of
simultaneously.
We are getting close to two thousand neurons now
but I think we need to increase this to about one hundred thousand to a million to start getting close to a picture
like when you do a camera or a movie. And you have just a few pixels of the image.
You cannot see very well but if you increase the number of pixels you start to see the granularity.
Is there seem more and more of the image
but you'll not necessarily need to have all the pixels of the of the photograph or the movie to see what is going on.
So I think if we crossed the barrier of a million neurons we caught a simultaneously.
We're going to see a lot of the movie that goes on in the brain.
Requires recording cemetery exactly just what I mean here. And here and.
You take three steps in this leg we feel you're sure. Yes we are we're probably three of you mean.
What you feeling in reality is a simulation of this five different steps that our patients and their goal
when they do the training.
OK So they first as I said they need to we need to remain certain the brain the concept of having legs.
So there's basically what we do.
We put them in a virtual reality environment that you can see in a moment
and the patient's time director with the avatar
and we now we are very you know we started just with the global concept of walking
but now we're actually simulating called to.
All of the specific muscles of walking which we never thought as patients would be able to do with their brains.
They're getting specialize in control individual legs.
We have one side of the brain for instance the right side controlling the left left leg left side comes from the right
leg but we discovered there. We can do a physical therapy by simulating muscle contractions on the video.
So they see a muscle or the leg contracting
and we develop the ability to contract individual muscles which is we never thought that would happen.
So that's the first step is the virtual reality then being go to the robotic device the robot standing on the treadmill.
To learn what it is to beneath the side of a robot because you should not underestimate how different is to being cased
in a robotic device is a complete different feeling of what you are. And since we are providing tactile feedback.
They're getting tactile feedback from their legs inside of their stand alone robot so that takes several months of
feeling that is normal.
So then we have our intermediate step where they go instanced in this system that we call zero gravity was zero G.
Where they're up right without a robot and they're practicing with just to be upright in
and trying to move with some ortho's is that we fabricate
and we give to them to practice because they're going to be in a hag's a skeleton.
We have another step that is just a mix of virtual reality and a stand alone robot
and finally they get into there is a skeleton just at the end of the process
and it takes in a few months for them to get to the point
and in the eggs are scared of them they now are using everything they learned in the previous steps to can use the
brain activity to control to trigger the movements are there is. Skeleton.
Now they can treat individual legs and they're getting the feedback from the feet as they walk on the ground.
And sometimes they walk on the ground just looking in a mirror to see their bodies walking upright because that helps
shape the brain's image of the body.
Sometimes they have gumbos because they're walking a virtual reality environment even though they're in exist Kelton
and sometimes they were just walking in a doing about fifty some steps back
and forth in these laboratories basically very by thinking Oh yes.
And that's exactly what we did this is the third prototype that we have there the first prototype was used during the
demo of the World Cup. But of course we had to struggle with Fifa.
You know because she for never gave us the conditions to actually do what we wanted in our
and I don't need to go into the details but from a three minute demo we're down to twenty nine seconds and
and which is almost literally impossible to do a robotic demonstration but it was important
and that is the Juliano pin to the guy who actually deliver the opening kick of the World Cup He trained on the pitch
on the grass for days and he delivered fifty seven kicks.
In his extra index a skeleton he had fifty seven attempts and he got fifty six correct. Which show you know there.
We are in the right direction.
The people can get used to these devices and they can actually start performing at a very high level of accuracy.
And of course we just started slow just with walking straight.
Now we're going to think about we are already planing turns and all other movements the patients want to have
but we are learning very quickly now.
So the beginning was very difficult because some of these patients that you saw were in a wheelchair for a decade with
no hope of nothing and and I can show you some of the movies that they haven't.
Their movements that they can make now you would be shocked.
What a paralyzed by rigor
and no no I'm talking about their own movement movements without the actual When you put them up. Now it is your A G.
Again. And you in the beginning you put them up and say move and nothing would happen.
They would stand and nothing would happen out.
You put them here in some of these patients can actually you see them doing this with their legs suggesting that we
reconnected. The brain to the spinal cord.
You know they're not reconnected and atomically
and atomically there were some nerves The survive there probably we reconnect to the functionally the brain can send a
message in the messages get into the muscles of our.
We look outside the line to the world really like where are you room it realize we're knowledge of your love for right.
Software how easy I want this is something that happened in the last five years
or so you know what I thought you know that my six years my study of neuroscience was too limited to what most there
are scientists do electrical signals of the brain competition our strategy is and behavior
and then I start thinking deeply with you know the help of my good friend run ups a career with a retired mathematician
and our flaws frames whistlin and I just came to a realization one day in Montreal what I
when I visit him why we do our work together and saying walking there. Actually when we talk about the brain.
We should not be limited to the kind of their physiological or a tonic whole
or neural lingo the nearest scientists talk about suddenly realize that the brain is the center of the human cosmology.
The brain is the crew true Creator of everything.
And I start to think about the whole universe as just raw information. Like a empty canvas.
And the brain has the true painter the human brain.
So I don't know if there are other brains out there
but everything that we have the history of the planet the history of the cosmos the history of the human race.
The jury of evolution everything that we we have conceived since the first human came out of the trees in the star
walking. If you could somehow some.
The amount of information knowledge process by every single human brain that every existed or exist or will exist.
That's the universe. That's the human universe. And I start thinking about it as changing viewpoint.
So first we thought of the earth was the center of the universe then we thought it was the sun.
And then we started was the Milky Way But then we thought another center universe is the big bang where everything came
of course there was something like The Big Bang. That must have been.
I actually start thinking that the center universe at least for our IF reference is our mind is the human brain.
And I start thinking about everything around us as information as raw information
and information that to get any meaning to get any any description needs a brain
and he so happens that the only one that we know is the human brain.
So I have a direct to experiment with run on the if some wonderful life form intelligent life form would come in
contact with us and we actually could talk to or communicate somehow. Their life form.
Assuming he had a brain that evolved to complete different laws of evolution in a different environment.
With There was a story of the cosmos. That is none of society ours.
And a completely different cosmology would be confronted with ours.
So I actually think the nearest sayas in this century may give us a hope to bring.
Humanity the human condition to the center of our lives.
In a position money or position
but to balance another movement that exists in the world right now there seems to say that technology may be able to
solve everything.
Their technology may be able to educate our kids take care of the elderly run our airports run our universities run our
knowledge gathering and eventually have you know some loonies say me replace us and I think this is crazy.
This is insane.
Technology is a projection of a much more complex thing called the brain when we create a machine like this
or a creator a car a plane. A computer or a robot.
We are just projecting our abstraction to our attention though device.
There is infinity of Lee less complicated than the Creator.
So the Creator is the mind and the human mind and that's reason I started thinking
and I must talk about philosophy I'm not a philosopher and know nothing about philosophy.
I'm talking about as a neuroscientist trying to use what I know about the brain.
To actually say that the brain has a point of view. The brain is not a passive decoder of the environment.
The brain shaped through evolution was shaped evolution by the environment by our genes by motivations
and everything but as we are born in we grow in the early phases of our lives we study Vella P.
A model of reality in an interpretation of reality in which the painting is an empty canvas.
And we we give them meaning to it and we create a story and we create history too.
You know and that's a much more profound in my opinion view of the brain
and the whole role of neuroscience then we're told before.
Any changes I think the balance if we believe in this the human can do.
And becomes a much more precious much more you know what I think the Life becomes much more precious than we thought
before because the epic of a single life. First of all cannot be reproduced ever. And it would never happen again.
It's like a book that will never be written again.
And I think it gives us a little more recognition as human beings then.
Currently they see the go the world going on in up and if I can just to finish that if you read the Eliade
or the Odyssey. Which I consider the pinnacle of human condition.
You know a description of the human condition when a soldier or a Greek soldier would die in Troy in a battle. Homer.
Describes who he was who are their parents who are the children to his living.
What is the whole history of that individual there will never be recovered so so compared that to the news of a death
in a newspaper today which is just a number. Nothing. Homer. You know God forbid three thousand years ago knew better.
What the human condition is than we probably know now we're losing that
and I think the process of losing it is part of our brains.
Thinking there is a really nice and good
and is worth it to mimic computers instead of maintaining our integrity our human condition integrity.
So for your scientific view. With sorrow. Yes we're our unique this now in terms of the way we look at the brain.
No no I think there are many people you know any people there.
Of course there are no one says you know is a is a big field than the brain is very complicated and the subtleties.
From a you know near physiological point of view and in up.
For instance people believe there do we should go deeper into the molecular structure of the brain.
I thought I find this fine from my intellectual point of view of course studying individual snaps
and I think I just don't think any of these will hours to explain how did the system works.
The system is is truly non-linear and new if you put your star a star in just a molecule.
You're not going to be able to track it back to the system it will be impossible.
The number non-linearity that you have to face so
but there are many people there realizing what we are discussing this now is not just the I would say honestly that is
not a mainstream yet but neither was Operation coding thirty years ago
when I started there are people gave me no hope of having a career in study populations of neurons
and here I am in OUR So I'm I'm used to.
The idea that you may start with notions and concepts they're not mainstream
and you need to demonstrate that they're worth.
That's part of what science is about the problem is science has become extremely conservative.
And is very difficult to break through when the idea is much more difficult than when I started when I was a kid
but you know we're stubborn. Yeah.
You know where you're VERY of your original work started five years in your future recently if you.
Well I think as you can see year.
This is going very quickly to clean a couple occasions I think are going to grow tremendously.
I think the basic science is going to evolve in the sense that we are going to see I mean we are celebrating the curve
of the number of neurons that we can record simultaneously. Used to be a very flat straight line.
It took us thirty years to get to a thousand two thousand
but now things are celery because we're learning better ways to do this my ambition to the end of my life is to be able
to actually formally.
This theory of of you know a comprehensive theory of the mind of the brain the way we are we talked just a minute ago.
And that's what I'm doing right now I'm spending a lot of time writing
and reading you know I'm I'm reading literature on communication
and Marshall McCullough Francis I became fascinated by what he used to say in the sixties
and seventies about the media been the message and how you know the communication has changed our nature
and from the moving from the oral tradition of poetry of the Greeks to written manuscripts then to the print to the
radio telegraph telegraph to radio T.V. Internet. I think they're actually he got it.
He didn't know anything about the brain.
But some of his writings in the sixties and seventies actually God how relevant communication is to synchronize brains.
And Arizona.
The human brain and it's going to be very well what we're doing
and I as a clinic up location that's what we're doing right now
and I want to see how that goes first I want to see if these are vintages to the patients because there's a very
concrete and tangible problem. To improve train.
But you can if suppose you have had to have a physical patient a patient there suffer a stroke that destroyed the left
side of the brain the cortex and he cannot talk but the right hemisphere is or is there
and there is some language capability left to live right hemisphere.
So pose you can connect this guy or someone else who can speak.
And you can synthesize a voice by having a brain at work with the stroke patient maybe you can improve the training of
the right hemisphere by persisted because we know it happens even in a drought patient if you don't have any lesion on
this side of justice you maybe try to improve the language skills. Of the right hemisphere.
So there's another thing that I want to start on because there's ten times more stroke victims in the world day
and spinal cord injury victims. So we're talking about a quarter of a billion people in the world with a stroke.
Consequents you know. So from where you develop your dream.
Where you can see more and more parking brake growth there but for some of these drug runners.
It's almost that you can react very you're by somebody else is active either by combining their brain
or someone I suppose your or your sibling in our your wife or your daughter or your son to help you in the training
and eventually it becomes a surrogate you know you can talk through this combination where you can communicate because
there are lots of patients also. They've become totally detached from the world.
They are cautious their brains are working to so they be absolutely conscious but for S.S.
All the muscles look areas disease of a left all the muscles of the body are part of life. So they cannot blink.
They cannot talk. They cannot breathe but they are cautious and their brain is fine.
The central part of the brain is totally fine. And these patients can barely communicate.
There is a brain machine interface for those patients that my friend had in Germany to bring in the news be bomber
created by the same time that we are doing experiments with rats we didn't even know each other that time.
That works but is phenomenal in news is a hero for this community but it can be improved and things can be better
and faster. So I think that's where we can go. And the more you can bring it to you for free to tradition.
Yeah
and that's that's one of my concerns that computers are not creative computers don't generate knowledge we do we get
right information and combine in ways that cannot be predicted. You know and that's reason I.
As we've talked before I like painting because painters.
I loved when they asked because so what the painting meant one of the two the paintings that he had of that day
and because I said well if I knew I would not have painted in his this is it this is deeper than Probably he meant for
me is and there are sites because it's true.
I think it's a says painting is more of an analog description of what we're thinking about what we're feeling this is a
projection to the outside world of some internal state of the mind and that's why I think this transition.
That we discuss are the Impressionists and in modern art. It was an explosion of form form disappeared.
You know why would the old guys they need to be very careful about reproducing every corner every shadow of a scene of
a person or you know modern art remove the concept of shape from painting and sculpture in.
Because it didn't matter anymore.
There was a next a complete different expressions who really is in
or could be isn't this is this is totally linked to the mind view of the brain in the face of trying to project what is
inside rather than taking a shot of what is out there in photography of course. Got this guy's out of business.
The guys who painted everything very in are just poor amateurs like to stew paint this thing but art.
You talk about creativity art and my concern is that if we become just computers part would disappear.
Computers don't do art the try to mimic they can compose artificial music that can do some taxed
but they don't carry the human condition in those letters and those brushes you know we do
and I feared complete with total allegiance and reliance on technology.
They destroy the human capability of being creative of doing art of doing the unexpected. You know.
And the other cultures where brands were star. Well when you saw our soccer fans and stadium and I think there.
I am I created this this is the metaphor in this operational definition of an organic computer.
We're going to computers basically multiple brains that get synchronizing nature by whatever signal visual tactile
auditory then makes them operate as a whole.
So the flock of birds is my best and a metaphor
or a school fish the flock if you look at the flock is very interesting because you're minimizing the chances of each
individual to be attacked by a predator. But you know do the birds change position in the flock.
Sometimes they have to go to the front and break the air they get tired.
They're moved to the internal center of the flock where they are most protected because they're tired
and by their birth they have to fly on the edge and at the edge.
They're more vulnerable but they are always rotating so the reasoning.
There's dynamics in this thing that is seems to be minimizing the chances of being caught.
If you're flying by yourself. Falcon may get you. You know eagle may get you much easier.
And as a flock the they are going to get to a source of food and they may get there.
Easier than just the individual birds looking you know. Saw birds and fish have memory like we do hear about.
Well one time is a complete different thing is a parallel track of my life and how that is starting to thousand
and two and a thousand. We're going to Thousand trailing President when I was elected here in Brazil.
I was already for a long time in the United States.
Fourteen years already and states and I saw the opportunity to actually return to Brazil
and do something not just to do science in Brazil was to use science as a complete different thing as an agent of
social development in part of Brazil that is well known for Brazilians as being the most underdeveloped part of the
country in the northeast of the country. And I wanted to prove dead human talent is everywhere.
Then you can go and just you know drop from power shoot in and in a place
and you start creating scientific infrastructure
and investing high level cation in a way that will transform this social reality of the community.
So I chose as meltdown in the outskirts of the capital on the humility to march estate and accept as not tell.
By the goodness it is actually mean is the name of a palm tree that is typical of the regime many had sixty five
inhabitants in the worst no human development index is in the state of
or going to the Marquis in one of the worst in the country.
And when we did was to go there
and create an parallel to a new state to do their science like a nice to do it to use the knowledge that we have is
there a scientist to design a education program that actually starts on the pre-made oh care of the mothers of our
future students.
So we because a human mortality or women mortality rate was very high but you get pregnant women mortality rate.
So at that time about ninety women per hundred thousand livres would die.
So very hyper thirty twenty thirty times higher than the you know you know you should have normally we create a clinic
and women's clinic to oversee the prenatal care of all the women in the region and to give an idea. We start from up.
Now we are doing.
Twelve thousand appointments a year
and we have been already sixty thousand appointments since we started which is which means that pretty much every woman
in this city that got pregnant in the last six seven years have gone through our prenatal care system is all free of
charge so public
and is the best prenatal care you can get the medicine can offer because there are scientists we knew then if you don't
provide the best possible prenatal care any problems then a child will have doing pregnancy can all be fixed is very
difficult almost impossible right now and in learning disability or any other malformation of the brain.
It will be corrected.
So how could you have a neuro science maze of the cation program
and offer these A students a chance to be born with the highest possible biological potential to achieve happiness
because that's my definition of integration is a pathway to happiness.
So we can in these indication program that it starts in the Premier Care in then we start rolling fifteen hundred kids
a year to three schools that we created too in that state
and one in another state in by year where the kids go in one part of the day to public school.
Which in Brazil is now full time and is just four or five hours a day
but on the all appear the day they would come to our schools in our schools in Micah even at how any second name by ear
all lab science oriented.
Even to learn Portuguese you learn in a lab and we basically make these guys this is students from that time from
and ten to fifteen years old and
when we open our new school in the campus of the brain that we're beauty one hundred get there.
Scampers in that region is taking a seven years to finish that the school is going to be from zero to seventeen.
So from the moment them born till then they can go to the nursery. To the moment they finish high school they're going.
To be in our school if they want about three thousand kids total
and then we are going to have a undergrad program in the campus for kids that want to pursue a scientific career
and master's in post-doctoral training.
So we're going to have a program that means that a kid can be there for thirty years. If they want.
Money in the case of these science education program that we created on day opposite period of the day from public
school.
These kids became protagonists in their own indication they basically got involved in learning as a as a pleasant
experience for and they develop antics of learning.
Then we never saw in their region in most parts of Brazil because they don't go to our schools because they have to go
because they want to and then school became a school not only for science
but for developing citizens says they're fully aware of their rights fully aware of their responsibilities in society
in fully aware this science and knowledge can be to passports for their happiness for India further education
and multiply to a point then we have already eleven thousand kids that have gone through is a school system
and for the first time in their place history in the neighborhoods next to it.
These kids and gaining access to the best universities in Brazil.
And in that region public universities where they could never make it because they never could past admissions exam.
Even though our schools will have exams. We don't do tests.
We don't believe in past so we don't believe in the Anglo-Saxon Punit if way of teaching we believe in to finish way we
don't we have replicated the Finnish approach to education in Brazil without knowing until very recently that we were
very soon a parallels with one caveat that the Finnish and not learn yet we do the Duke Asian since the prenatal care.
So in now the women our partners to in on that we created a community there.
He's very supportive of everything we do because different from most universities in the world.
There really are these beautiful paradises of knowledge
but this rounding parts of the university have nothing to do the university
and have no idea what is going on inside the doors.
I see that particularly in our own United States
and even here in Brazil we create a campus there has no walls is totally opposed to the community in the community has
learned to value of science because science is not for papers books publications in that position knowledge science in
that how in my cable we demonstrated science can also be an agent of social and economic transformation.
Because in addition to promoting education and women's health. We have created a whole cascade of jobs.
And I hire production line of support. Suppliers people to make. Construction work because we have beauty and campus.
So it's very nice to see the funders of our children building this campus.
They they work for the construction company that has built
and the first two beauties of the ninja game to get to that twelve thousand square meter
and the research institute in the India twelve thousand square meter school.
Oh I know my new book about the Natalee my cut my cable project is how to beat zero topia a scientific social topia
because you know in our days of top it has become almost like a curse word a negative word
and I disagree frontally with that I think that we have to have a pope is in dreams even if we don't fulfill them
completely is very important to be gauging one because of the process makes us want to get out a house or a house
and go out here in this pretty tough cruel world and naturally do something concrete. And in that pile.
I think that's what happened and we had Brazilians coming from all over the country teachers scientists
and physicians and the strangers technicians and who believed in these Autopia
and now they can put their hands on these walls and we can see these kids getting to the university
and so is a very rewarding experience effect is one of the things that when I go to the power
and all I feel the real me of science.
And when I look at here and dissipate sions and I go to that how I actually feel it was worth it.
You know this thirty five years of work. Oh absolutely.
We need dreamy for a variety of reasons
but a neuroscientist Yes I think if you if you equate as a reason discussed before if we equate narrow science
or any science just with technology of element. You're missing the most important part of it is the.
Dream is this creativity is trying to answer questions and nobody has ever asked or nobody ever had an answer for
and so the first time to John shape it and I recorded.
Twenty six there no simultaneously in that little rant in our labs in the middle of the night.
First get to me
and then there was a good thing we could share a lawyer for divorces because in a weird five in the morning recording a
red brain. In our lifes will never believe that we're actually doing it.
By the second thing we thought both of us in Philadelphia in ninety one was this is going to change everything.
Nobody knew
but we knew we were different ones to see those twenty six limbs find together in me some little one for us.
That was the universe. You know that was the thing that changed our lives.
You know if it's well yeah I think his guys live in a bubble.
You know they're very interesting things they have created and they're very interesting as they have.
Changed the world that have created but they're not the gods of the universe.
They think they are in there a lot of home race and arrogance there too.
And there's a very a lot of talented people and I want to very gifted people interested to go to San Francisco
and I asked opinions of people who live in San Francisco before this thing exploded Silicon Valley
and what is going on there because a lot of people there believe that technology will solve all our problems
and that's not through our problems will be solved by the good old fashion way of humans interacting
and trying to find a consensus to live together through democracy to to gauge
when to social engagement to recognizing that not everybody is born.
And disabled Bertone it is
and we need to increase the opportunities to everybody in trying to look for a way to so everybody can see happen is an
achievement and a good amount of it and then perhaps everything that good amount of good that is
and makes life decent for everybody
and to believe that they were willing to solve all the problems of the universe through Facebook or Twitter
or to robots
or fission talents is ludicrous is in fact in my opinion a new wave of captivity is wearing you meet the E.U.
You have to read Jews as a human value and you have to devalue the human contribution.
Because then if you reduce human cost of labor human creature profits to infinity as a very well known equation in you
cannot eliminate the human value is obvious you know and but so in some senses when I'm very main science.
Some of the prophecy is that these groups like Carswell and others have made that we are going to be replace
and not only fullish in Basan any scientific data they're dangerous in my opinion they actually confront.
It's really the fact there has to be an answer to that in the answer is dead. We're humans in our.
And we most value most precious. Capabilities and not out there for additional computer to replace.
Her problems in the directing the venue of the human species in my opinion in millions
and millions billions of years of evolution that took us from a base of rock
or the Stardust to a thinking creative non-conformist human brain
and he's destroying the fabric of humanity in my opinion and so we need to be aware of it in confront as guys. Yet.
Maybe start off the most. Is very brave. And here.
When you when we look around all the metaphors says is if you want room with Barton. So it's not us.
Are you saving grace so much acted out.
Yeah well that's the difference of a technician in a scientist my professor here in Brazil which was the father of
their science in Brazil says a Cheerio always told me there's a big difference between a technician in a scientist
or a technician been to give those and run things like a robot a scientist thinks like a human.
And thinks about science in Brother terms than just it a specific field or a specific area of his or her work.
I think we said.
Interests almost need my I didn't by default to have a very profound and deep intellectual background
and we need to think about the consequences of what we do you know the legacy of what we do
and the way our science is used.
We didn't talk about this
but there's a very new danger of weaponize in the brain in I'm totally opposed to it because this is the last frontier
in I don't want to see what I did when I created called brain machine interfaces being used to harm or kill people.
And so on.
Well you can imagine this is happening now in some places
but you know the one states where the Bundy face is thinking about using being machine interfaces to create weapons.
You know that humans can control just by thinking.
And I frontally opposed this and I think it is important in a scientists and speak out.
You know against this kind of use of this research was that these three groups or all of us
and our only hope is society because we scientists push the envelope to discover what is possible
but is society's duty and right to regulate what can be done with this knowledge. You know around the world and.
When you see face. Yeah.
It's more of a show yet that what people are thinking there is totally I mean I mean he's totally for me unethical.
You know what are well to think about
and blame thousand soldiers with electrodes to record brain tissue that can be used to control guns or weapons
or whatever.
I don't know the detail because I refused to even listen to the details
but this is a debate that has to be done among scientists and society not only among neuroscientists Yes. It's a sign.
We now know you'll get signals from the brain to control a machine gun must miss I lunching you ice
or God knows what I don't know or ends a skeleton for a soldier to tune into world war.
You know that's not what I had in mind when I created this technology. This is what I had in mind. You know.
This world. We're Great Britain.
Yes we're how far from home while in there's a I told you I have this point I don't have I have just soo positions in
hints in a gut feeling to describe it. I can tell you a precisely what he called the light.
I think about as I told you but they show up locations that can be beneficial to mankind
and to people who are suffering from disorders or diseases and
but I don't I don't even think about so I fight scenarios that are harmful and I only want it.
Yet while I think that if we could communicate better if we could find a way of communication.
Then you know he's more natural and better perhaps who would figure it out that we all the same.
That we have the same fears no matter where you come from.
We have same aspirations they have same desires we're all humans by the way in
and I look at you know things like the refugee crisis in Europe in perhaps my brain to brain communicating would
realize that we are all coming from the same place in and by the way the place was Africa. You know.
And so racism and prejudice and prejudice based on economic differences on the nation.
You know all of this things would disappear if we could somehow convince people that we had goes through in our brains
is the same thing. It's the same stuff and want to bring is produced is the same in the future more and more.
I hope it could become more
and more liberating effect if you read Arthur Clark's three thousand one of the last book of his.
Series that he started to Thousand and One in on it.
He starts the book with something called Brain caps in two thousand and one in people communicate by brain caps.
You know INTO IT TELLS I want to we're you know why he would be happy to know that we have thousand years earlier in
getting some of this stuff to work.
Of course what he described I don't think will ever happen but
and what is interesting to see that neuroscience can even computer science fiction. OK.
He didn't do much of a dark yet see we're already on I why I always want to ask Cameron where he got the idea because
he claims he had a dream. We had published many Scientific American papers before he had that dream I think so.
I'm always will. Wonder what he got that idea of having a guy you know was she controlling and I have a pair.
The so because this was out there you know I would be very very curious to ask in one way he really got the idea.
You know that's the director of the film.
You know your camera business or technical aspect is one of the many things they're not possible.
Of course and then he just made it up which is did vanish a science fiction to us so we can all make it up.
Everywhere you were never what you were doing before or since you were for a moment.
So it's sort of YOUR it's from what is special one word yet where I tell my students always imagination is always the
limit here. You know we end. In these labs.
We're not here to do it in the name of the incremental things we're they had to push the limit of their science.
You know and this is what you could. Yes but of course the timescale is not tomorrow. But.
I like to work with people that. Likes that deal. You know to do of thinking far ahead and trying to make it happen.